good evening everyone and welcome to
this evening's meeting of the northwest
area planning committee um i would like
to start with apologies for we've had
some technical issues and i'm afraid
we're a little bit late starting
i'm very sorry but we'll try and crack
on now
my name's councillor maddie thompson i'm
the chairman of this committee
before we commence the business there
are a few housekeeping issues to run
through we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you are giving
your consent being recorded
when invited to speak please turn on
your microphone and speak clearly
referencing a page and or parallel
paragraph number when rejec referring to
the agenda papers
keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible and ensure your
microphones remain off when not actually
speaking as this is important for the
live streaming to be heard clearly
finally can i draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda papers with
regards to the different levels within
the chamber and advise that the fire
exit is that one the door behind the top
table
members mo draw your attention to the
members update with further information
on item five on the agenda
right our item two is apologies for
absence um miss bird i believe we have
none this looks like a full house to me
that's right
thank you thank you very much item three
is the minutes of the last meeting it's
recommended that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 7th of july in this
chamber found on pages 7 to 10 are
approved as a true and accurate record
may i take them as read members
i so propose do i have a second uh
thank you i believe councillor morley
was the first one to second um are there
any matters of accuracy any member
wishes to raise
okay can i can we agree those
ascent members
anybody disagree
thank you
right item four is a declaration of
interest and the wording is now
different from that in the published
agenda apologize for that the council
has adopted the new updated code of
conduct so i'll read the current wording
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable pecuniary interests
other registerable interests and
non-registrable interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regard to paragraph nine and dependent b
of the code of conduct for members
members are also reminded they're
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should they
need a rise through the meeting might
have councillor done's
borrowing first
thank you chairman um i think it's
probably a non-registerable
interest now um as a member of essex
county council whatever interest it is
that's
quite but
it's not pecuniary it's not pecuniary
failing council of plumbing is about to
tell us
i think it's a registrable interest
then it's a registrable interest thank
you
interest
um councillor
fleming um i won't take that as your
interest because you didn't say it was
but
thank you chair um yes a registered
interest as a member of essex county
council who are statutory consultees
thank you thank you anybody else
councillor councillor stevenson
thank you chair um it's not an interest
i just wanted to point out that i've
resigned from tallsbury's neighborhood
planning team so that i don't have an
interest thank you thank you um could we
note that miss bird please and i
appreciate it it's not an interest but
it might be of interest
oh sorry councillor mike i'm sorry i'm
thank you chairman um
under um the clermont garden center
application i think he's a gender right
of six
and i don't know the applicants and but
i have
warm
um unless you had a special deal for
being a counselor
then it is
oh it has changed hands hasn't it yeah
i've not been in there since it's
changed hands um well i'm sure you know
whether to note that or not miss bird i
actually don't think that's terribly
important okay
item five is our first planning
application on the agenda that's land
northwest of 48
north sorry at 48 tolsbury road there is
a members update in relation to this
item of business
we have the presentation from miss boles
please and then we have three speakers
to follow that thank you
thank you chair and there is a verbal
update for this item um the proposal
does read consisting of 29 affordable
dwellings and it should read
um just 25 dwellings so that has been
amended
um also at paragraph 6.4.2
bullet point three um it should read
management company not management
community
so this item was deferred um well planet
festival planning permission is sought
to create a residential
neighborhood for older people consisting
of 25 dwellings a community hub building
with associated landscaping
and infrastructure the application was
deferred at the northwest committee
meeting on the 30th of march 2022
and the application has been revised
with the amendments to the scheme fully
set out within paragraph 5.1.1
of the officer's report the main changes
relate to the affordable housing scheme
um and there has been a reduction of
four residential units
and associated changes to the layout and
design
so we've got the location plan
and this is the block plan
and we've got the previous um schemes
block plan here
and you can see there has been a
reduction in the density of the
development in the south
west corner here
and around the courtyard if i
look back
you can see it's less less dense
so then we've got the
um landscape of the courtyard area
landscaping that's this area
here
then we've got the um proposed elevation
roof and floor plans the overall design
of the dwellings remains largely in line
with the previous scheme there has been
minor amendments to plots 1 and 2 11 and
12 and 17 to 22.
sees plots one and two
this three and four
we've got five and six
seven to ten which is a block of floor
i'm sorry four flats
and then we've got the proposed
elevations for
eleven and twelve
these three plots 25
and then we have the community building
which has remained unaltered
and the street scene elevations
then we've got some photos of the
application site itself
under the area surrounding the site
and of withdrawal road
the revised scheme given the reduction
in the quantum of development and the
revised affordable housing scheme would
provide a development that meets local
housing needs the original concerns in
relation to the affordable sales element
of the proposal and the type of
development which previously did not
meet the district's needs are now
considered to have been overcome
whilst significantly reduced given the
amendments to the scheme the harm of the
development on the character and
appearance of the area is acknowledged
however the benefits arising from the
development weigh significantly in favor
of the proposal and considered to
outweigh the harm therefore the
application is recommended for approval
thank you chair
thank you
sorry i've just been asked to press some
buttons here
um
right now we now move on to the public
speakers so miss bird um do we have mr
appleton ready because he's going to
speak by our
and if the teamsters could just minimize
that screen and bring the team screen on
you should see mr appleton ah that's
what i was going to say
there we go right um mr appleton can we
just reset that clock so we don't steal
three seconds from mr appleton by mr
appleton you have two minutes precisely
from when you start to speak um
off you go when you're ready when you're
comfortable
thank you chair my name
i've worked in the is of accommodation
and care for older people for the past
40 years i'm the author of a number of
publications dealing with the production
of strategies for accommodation with
care for older people and the
specification of such accommodation
these were commissioned by the
department of health and the nato
department for communities and local
government
in addition to supporting funding
initiatives
my work helped shape the housing lead
shopback toolkit which is the council's
the basis of the council's own
calculation of need for accommodation
for older people
i'm familiar with the development
proposal in this application i want to
offer the committee just four points
which set the broader context for their
consideration on it
as a society we have failed to respond
appropriately to the challenges
presented by an aging population leading
to a situation the national planning
practice guidance of june 2019
characterized as critical
if it's true nationally it's even more
true i have to say more
appropriate specialised housing not only
enhances and preserves the independence
and well-being of the individuals who
live there
but also helps mitigate increasing
demands on aging population places on
health and social care services
benefits acknowledged in the adult
social care by paper of december last
year
and in the report on housing from the
house of lords built environment select
committee which was published in may of
this year
we need to facilitate a range of options
as diverse as the needs and
circumstances of the older population
this application is designed to meet
local needs
i'm sorry i have to stop you there i'm
always very strict with everyone so
thank you very much
thank you
next speaker is representing the parish
council that's the chairman council
plato it's a pleasure if you come
forward
i know you know the rules but just pick
a chair please use the microphone
and you have two minutes precisely
from when you start speaking to make
yourself comfortable thank you
madam chairman councillors simon plato
i'm the chairman of telstra parish
council i'm an architect
i hope that you have all read the
information that we have provided and
understand the position the parish is
facing with regard to the unknown effect
of climate change over the next 50 years
sea level is rising it is happening
but by how much is still
unknown or vague
storms in the north sea are increasing
and consequently we are beginning
to experience more surge tides than we
have ever known
these surge tides at some time will over
top the low part of the sea wall in
tullesbury
if a high storm tidal surge coincides
with a high spring tide
then tullesbury will face a very serious
problem with tidal flooding which could
potentially affect this site
the parish council having considered the
current information released
by the ea
and the met office and having monitored
the weather and tides over the last year
are of the opinion that the risk of this
happening
would seem real
serious and inevitable
given this position the parish council
has reluctantly recommended refusal of
this development as it does not feel it
should be putting future residents at
risk damaging their homes and their
personal finance
this site is unfit for this purpose
please refuse the application thank you
and last but certainly not least we have
the applicant mr swell
again i know you know the rules but it's
please make yourself comfortable
use the microphone and you have two
minutes
good evening everyone over the past two
years this site has received the backing
of experts across the board we have
received 125 letters of support from
local people representing older
residents in malden
to be clear there have been no technical
objections despite three full
re-consultations
22 personal objections were received
their arguments are varied not in
response to expert opinion but according
to those which generate the most anxiety
this small group does not reflect the
interests of people that need this
housing those for whom the changes
happening in the world right now pose
the greatest threat
i would ask that this committee bases
their decision on the recommendation of
officers and the evidence and are not
swayed by baseless conjecture such as
tidal flooding and blocked drains which
have been dismissed by the experts the
lead local flood authority anglian water
and the environment agency
a local resident geraldine baker cannot
be here due to her husband's poor health
but she gave me permission to quote the
letter that she sent to you all
salt meadows is an innovative scheme for
retirement not only would it suit us but
also numerous other older people in
similar circumstances
my husband has lewy body dementia this
is a degenerative disease and a move to
affordable retirement living is
essential
we have lived and worked in tullesbury
for 50 years and our children have been
brought up here and experienced the
wonderful life it offers
we do not want to move away from the
area and lose the support network we
have to help with my husband's condition
and become lonely and isolated
the housing crisis facing older people
is very real
our proposal will give local older
people on lower incomes more choice and
more security
please support this application and the
local residents such as geraldine and
her husband
who need your help
um
right members um i'll open the
discussion and i hope at some point a
proposal will come out of that but
one thing i do have to say is we are in
the hands of our statutory authorities
and that is the only view we can take
into account whether it's
highway
environment agency anglian water
um
i don't live very far from tollsbury i
represent part of tullesbury and i know
issues have been brought up you know and
they are legion
but we cannot consider anything that is
not
the evidence of the statutory
authorities
in the report
okay members would like to go first
councilman morgan
oh yes thank you madam chairman um i was
just really following up on that and the
somewhat apocalyptic uh view of
the future that the tullesbury parish
council has us to the future of their
village i was just wondering
how what officers can say in in that
regard as to what exactly the
environment agency or need anyone else
has said in regards to the potential
flooding possibilities of this site when
you're coming to your decision to uh
approve
someone for you
so thank you chairman um as officer paul
explains the environment agency haven't
raised any objection with the proposal
in relation to flood risk
we are working with the evidence and
information we have at the moment what
can and may happen in the future
you know
which may well be unfortunately is not
consideration for
us as decision makers it is about the
evidence we have now currently thank you
chairman
can i just
follow all sorry different matters on
the section 106 agreement you
have said that you're building in a
thing for cascade mechanism in terms of
the way
these
properties are going to be allocated can
you just explain how that works
bhm yep that'll be similar in nature to
what we've accepted and had at uh
the retirement community outside of
burnham so it will look at local
residents first and then expand out um
see one of these obviously all these
applications are aimed at meeting the
need of our residents so the idea is
that primarily it will do that first
obviously if there is no need for our
residents whether it's
when it's built out or 10 15 20 years
time then that will allow accommodation
for other people though but it's the
idea is it will
go out in a gradual process
that mechanism will be good for each
time a property becomes vacant to music
thank you councillor dharama have you
next thank counselor keith and
councilman yeah thank you thank you
chairman yeah i think you you've made it
very clear that we have to rely on our
statutory council days which includes um
the lead flood authority which cause our
essex
um
and in fact you you were present the
other day chairman when professor priti
who chairs the essex climate commission
um made a presentation in
know though he tollsb concern it wasn't
an apocalyptic situation for
um certainly for the immediate 50 years
i'm not you know
we know we're facing an issue unless
something is done but that's the whole
point we are mitigating or that
we are as a country as a county and
hopefully globally we are looking to
mitigate
the rising in um
overall temperatures um
there are there is a floodgate in
tullesbury and i'm wondering if we if we
know how many times that has been closed
recently
um
because floods let's face it floods are
not new i know we are currently
experiencing weather events we got one
at the moment which is i quite like but
um
we do have to be mindful of climate
change quite rightly
but you know we we had a big flood in
1953 which was
may or may not have been
um due to climate change we don't know
so
if we don't have the information on on
how much that
how often the floodgates are closed then
we have to rely on our statutory
consultee's responses i'm sure council
stevens will
tell us when we get to her well i hope
but i suspect the answer might depend on
whether the environment agency can find
the key
um counselor keys
thank you madam chairman um
beyond the ndc planning applications it
says a total of 145 people were
constantly consulted comments receiver
150
two objections 22 supporting 125.
that speaks for itself and what i can
see it was one on the pill in 2016
and for appealing
i probably don't look that old but i
remember when there were stable blocks
on that plot
and quite substantial stable blocks if
my memory
is correct
and
yeah i
can't see and you just see you took some
of my thunder accounts for durham so
leave it as that thank you
i won't try and guess your age council
keys i shall move on to councillors
thank you can i start with some
questions please not to do with flooding
but other things um in the report it
refers to it being sheltered
accommodation can i just be clear that
this isn't i think a lot of us would
imagine that sheltered accommodation
involves a warden of some sort um i'm
not quite clear what the shelter is
meant to be can i ask a bit more about
that please thank you
yeah
see you chairman um
yeah
shelter accommodation doesn't mean it
has to be uh
someone on site you know quite often it
can be done remotely
we haven't got any details about how
that would be specifically delivered but
i think we can make an assumption that
it will not be resonant on site by the
fact that there is no uh specific unit
of accommodation for that but
i don't see that it's from two situation
either way in termination of the
application thank you thank you
in actual fact all that changed from my
recollection with the european working
time directive
because i remember a family member
that suddenly wasn't a warden on site
anymore because they were deemed to be
at work all the time they were on site
even if they were asleep
so wardens in sheltered housing
have become something of a thing of the
past
for those reasons and very likely others
but i think you'll be pushed to find
anyone who lives on site these days
thank you chair yeah i mean i have long
current and previous experience of that
so i know wardens don't live on site i
just have a feeling there is no warden
associated with this at all even
off-site but because i haven't seen any
evidence to the contrary so i just want
people to be aware that this might not
be quite sheltered as
one might like anyway my next question
is about the sequential test um
when this came up before there had not
been a sequential test
um
i think our policy is that most older
persons housing should be in malden hey
bridge in vernon where there's most
demand for it and best access to
amenities and public transport
which clearly this isn't um has the
sequential test being fulfilled now
because i don't see that in the revised
report thank you
food chain i'm unclear on where any
policy requirement requires a sequential
test for uh
this development so i can't really
comment they're not tomorrow because
there is no plus requirement for a
sequential test to be undertaken
i don't really understand that because
it does say um
somewhere in here that no sequential
test had been conducted and i don't
think that would have been referred to
if it weren't necessary
i'm sorry forgive us while we look as
i'm sure
page 54 which i think is part of
it's a bit confusing when you're going
through this report because you don't
know when you're looking at an
individual paragraph whether it's in the
old report or the new report
some colors would be marvelous as just a
side suggestion um
but anyway for you chairman if anyone
wants to know it's in the old report on
the new report the top of every uh
page that relates to the old report as
appendix a for clarity so that will uh
cis
sorry we are a little slowed down by the
original the case officer he is away
hence
this is trying to cover for
three chairman yeah it does make says
there is no squinting test but this but
as it says in the policy thing above
there is no requirement to obviously
that is in the old report so i'd be in
the current poll it's not um but yeah
there is no requirement for sequential
tests to be undertaken
thank you chairman
it seems peculiar to to mention it in
that case but uh i'll take your word for
that thank you um
with the section 106 agreement um
is the income cap
index linked please thank you
do you chairman like all monies
requirements for the section 106 yeah
they will be index linked
thank you um
[Music]
where it refers to a value of a home
does it mean the asking price or the
selling price because the value is sort
of a nebulous thing thank you
see you chairman can can members
obviously be helpful if you take me to
exact paragraph if you're going to be
asking specific questions and as always
if you've got a lot of complex questions
i would encourage that they are provided
to talk to us beforehand rather than
having to uh answer them on the hoof
okay it's pretty challenging but that's
obvious the report states it's some 20
discount on the local market values
that'll be the value that the
market evidence is a property should be
thank you
i've got a page for that
it's page 25 sorry thank you
and there was a get out clause as it
were that allowed the seller to
ignore if you like the occupancy
criteria for it being a local person if
the property hasn't sold after 13 weeks
and i'd like to know if that's still in
there or if it's been removed please
because house sales just always take
more than 13 weeks so i felt that it was
a bit meaningless really thank you
see you chairman um standard practice to
have a
a reasonable period of time for uh
the uh
brains come back like for the property
to be marketed obviously there'd be a
difference we're not the legal
requirement won't be it'll be need to be
sold within that period because
as you said that takes longer but it
will be a relation to a period of market
and not in and not had any appropriate
uh
interest or anyone looking to take out
the property and as i said this is
standard and it's what we did at the
same at other sites so it's consistent
to
malden district council's approach thank
you thank you
okay thank you um so then
the last page of my notes is about
flooding
and i am concerned about flooding i hear
what we say about the consultees
the environment agency has released
figures very recently
which say that sea levels are going to
rise by or they predict that sea levels
will rise by 1.2 metres and that surges
will rise by 2.2 meters so you add those
together you've got 3.4 meter potential
rise over what we have at the moment
um
in february tullesbury had a high tide
of 3.7 meters so if you had that 3.4
metre rise
to what we're experiencing now
that brings you up to 7.1 meters
and the highest point of the site is 6.7
meters
so i remain very concerned
i
i'm not a great fan of this kind of
development but i absolutely see that
people want it i hear hear what
residents are asking me a lot of people
are saying to me i really want to move
into these houses emma and i'm thinking
but you don't want to go through a flood
and given that the environment agency is
also predicting that surge tides are
going to become much more frequent once
a year this isn't going to be a flood
you claim on the insurance you buy a new
bed and a new sofa and carry on you'd be
looking at the same again and the same
again and then it will become
uninsurable
and i think there's quite a
straightforward way around this which
would be to include some sort of
i think you call it a bund
a sort of inner inland sea wall if you
like around the bottom end of the site
but i don't see anything about that in
the plan so i wonder
what we think about that would that be
possible could we condition it perhaps
thank you
see you chairman the council and the
statute consultants have no concerns in
relation to flooding it would be
unreasonable to include that it would be
owners and go beyond any requirement
that we would be able to defend our
appeal and it would be a very dangerous
condition to impose i would suggest
thank you chairman
thank you
i'll come straight to you councillor
siddhelbaugh i'm gonna stick when they
can i'm not i'm not telling anyone what
they should or shouldn't think i'm just
trying to explain when i speaking about
the statutory authorities
that's what we're obliged to follow
that's what the planning inspector will
follow
i absolutely recognize people's concerns
um
i used to live on a barge on the
saltines in tollsbury and i can remember
one night having to stay aboard and keep
licking out the horses so that we didn't
just disappear underneath
but this is
sorry
those were the days
but this is also unpredictable
this is the problem and this is why it's
difficult to pin the environment agency
down and why they don't particularly
want to be
pinned down i'd share your concerns i do
know
one of the parish councillors behind
this i know
as well as being a world-class
ornithologist coastal farmer expert the
college expert on many of these matters
but we need
hard evidence
to make a decision on it i'm sorry to
have held you up councillor
thank you chair uh so yeah a lot of what
we've heard tonight is conjecture
and that and that's the issue
that we as councillors have got to deal
with in terms of making this decision
because they are not material
consideration in terms of making this
decision
we don't know what's going to happen in
the future in terms of sea walls in
terms of flooding yeah and in terms of
what might be and that applies to the
whole of the molten district not just
this particular site but the whole of
the molden district so
i personally can really see the need for
this type of development in the malden
district we are an ageing population we
have a large age of of of over 60s i'm
in that category now uh yeah in terms of
that that situation
so i i i can see the concerns of of you
know of of people who in tulsa and of
the parish council however i cannot see
that those concerns
become a material consideration so
therefore i would like to propose that
we agree the officer's recommendation
secondly
i think i had councillor keys
was the first pour up on that
right councillor
darum thank you councillors
now we have something council very
eloquently said you know it is
conjecture and and i'm afraid it is and
and i think we have to be completely
realistic
if and
we all hope it doesn't come to the
the worst case scenario with predictions
there won't be anything left along the
thames corridor holland won't exist
and
large parts of this district
won't um and that's why as i said that's
really why
we all need to work really hard to
tackle climate change
and as i said
who knows if we had a crystal ball it
would be marvelous
but we haven't got it and we have to
make our decisions based on
the evidence and the facts assad now
um and yes okay i accept the fact that
we may be
god forbid creating a problem for our
forebears but
we i sincerely hope we're not
uh so chairman yeah i i uh again support
this application it is uh it's quite an
attractive development and
um as we've seen there is quite clearly
um a local
a local liking for it as we've seen
as we have and although it isn't
attached to malden or hey bridge or
burnham tollsbury is as we know quite a
long way out a lot of people that is
where a lot of people
want to stay i would if i were a
tollsboo quite possibly even though i'm
not councillor fleming
thank you chair i just wanted to ask the
officers about um eco measures i didn't
see any ev charging points and also
i'm quite keen on water butts now as
we're in a drought
um i'm just conscious that we need to be
designing for
for our weather at the moment so um
maybe i've missed it but i didn't see
much focus on that thank you
dude chair and what can you say
generally and i've said it before and
i'll probably have to say it again
because i'll get asked these questions
is that the mppf only talks about
ecology and improvements environmental
things in relation to
the environment such as renewable etc
plan making
these things have a financial cost to an
application and there is an expectation
that they will be delivered through
policy and our policies don't require
anything of that so um we you know it
wouldn't be reasonable to acquire extra
requirements above and beyond our ldp
policy and what i'd highlight in
relation to
charging points is that's now where
building
regulations matter so planning isn't too
uh
you know where there's different
variations of uh
um
that's the one that's centered but we
actually the third question
condition 36 which does require charging
points but they're still required for
building rigs anyway so
it would be a bit of a better embraces
thank you
yeah thank you if i can come back so
miss lee you're saying that we can't put
in measures like must have water butts
and and gravel drives and things like
that no
we can't put that in as an informative
chairman um informative obviously it's
just the informative we can put any
informative on we want it has no legal
merit or why um but yeah
any additionality that
you know these things
comes back to the you know like example
you know with affordable housing etc
there's only so much cake want a better
phrase and when you do the local plan
you have to decide how you cut that you
know modern has a high percentage
affordable housing you know another
authority might have more requirements
in relation to ecology or environmental
measures and obviously would then affect
that the plan we have is the plan we
have and there is very limited
requirements to deliver environmental
benefits through that plan and anything
above that we do not have an ability to
ask for thank you
thank you
we can ask mind you council fleming we
can drop very heavy hints and look for
thumbs up from the applicants
um
but we have a local plan review
that's where we change the policies i
believe oh councillor white um i've got
your counselor counselor but councillor
white hasn't spoken
thank you
but i i have to say it's already
mentioned everywhere between about a
half days for the flooding if the
environment agency and the local leave
like the agency say there's no risk to
the flooding we cannot refuse it on
those reasons because we will lose it
appeal and it will cost a lot of money
um notwithstanding that which we can't
learn about i like the development like
all of us we're getting older i think
this is a lovely retirement village it's
not got lots and lots of sandwiches on
one side i think it's a really good sign
and i agree with the proposal you should
agree with that
thank you
all right i've got very quickly please
counselor keys and counselor darren i
think yeah i think captain
mr lee might have said it um the
business i'm involved in at the moment
um we've just put up a shop and in
brighton hope they have to have bee
bricks in them is there anything we
could
put or you just said you'll go and buy
it for but it's no environment thing i
know mrs fleming's just said it but i've
just been down the path of b bricks
i i think
oh so sorry i'll save you the trouble mr
lee i think if it isn't in our policies
we can ask
and and i'm saying yeah i think your
thumbs up somewhere council fleming
thank you well could we put this sort of
thing in as an informative and then as
the north west we can always ask for it
and then eventually applicants will say
well actually that's what the north west
committee would really like to see
so i just think it sets a tone if we
start asking for things like water butts
likely skirt the proper procedure ask
councillor sidler's proposal if he's
prepared to consider adding that his
proposal isn't informative otherwise we
get to vote on the change on the
amendment and then go back to
councillor how do you feel about it i'm
a great believer in water butts
excellent
um and i'll say anything that mitigates
standing water and making sure that
water does flow away so things like
gravel drives and membranes and not hard
of services
so if you're happy to adopt that into
the proposal
secondary
thank you and so are you done councillor
kiso councillor durham i'm just going to
be really very very quick because i know
i've heard what mr leo said we can't
condition it we can't even do an
informative but chairman you were there
at the public meeting last week with
professor pritti at tullesbury i think
the applicant or the agent was there as
well they would have heard
professor pritty advocating the
installation of solar panels on roofs i
hope the applicant was listening because
as professor priddy said that is
actually going to be a requirement in
the fairly near future
and i'm sure that photovoltaic um panels
on the roofs will make the
properties much more saleable because
they'll be much more economic to run and
i hope the applicant has listened but
it's entirely up to them thank you
just
isn't it
that would need a new application so i
think we'll leave
right i'm actually going to put this to
the vote because what with the delay
starting
so those
i think that's tempting to the
chairman's charity isn't it
right
members those in favor of the proposal
to agree the officer's recommendation
with a couple of tweaks in the name of
councillor siddal
any that looks unanimous to me oh no it
isn't sorry anyone against
councillor stevens is against so there
are no abstentions no detentions okay
have you got that whisper
thank you very much and moving on now to
item
six clermont garden center brian
slainwood and mortimer
there's no update on this one members um
stango would you give the presentation
thank you yes thank you chairman
[Music]
the applicant seeks planning permission
for the construction of a detached
building at the garden center to be used
as a cafe office and staff room
this application follows a previously
approved application in 2017
for an extension to the existing garden
center incorporating a new coffee shop
and retail areas
the previous application expired on no
13th of november 2020 and the council
has no evidence that the development was
ever commenced however the applicant has
stated that the new access to the site
approved as part of the previous
application was implemented it would
therefore appear that the applicant
considers that the previous permission
is extent
this is the site location plan for the
application
and the site is located on the northern
side of maldon road at oak corner
and is located outside of the defined
settlement of wood and mortimer within
the countryside where policies of
constraints apply
this is the existing block plan for the
application showing the existing garden
center buildings to the east
existing polytunnels to the west and an
informal parking area to the south here
this is the block plan that was approved
as part of the previous application
showing the extended garden center here
as well as a covered external storage
area or sales area sorry
this is the proposed block plan showing
the proposed cafe building in place of
the existing polytunnel
with the new polytunnels replaced to the
rear of the cafe building
also shown is a proposed walkway
which can be accessed by the extended
car park to the south
and also connects the garden center and
the
cafe building
um
and also shown is a landscaped area to
the west
this is the proposed floor plan of the
cafe building
as well as
a modest greenhouse to the front of the
building
these are the proposed elevations
this is the proposed street scene
elevation showing the existing garden
center
and the new cafe building
and these are existing photographs
uh exist a photograph of the existing
garden center buildings facing west
and facing east
and this is the existing external
storage area to the west of the garden
center buildings
this is the existing polytunnel where
the proposed cafe building would be
located
and these are views of the site from
malden road
in line with the assessment carried out
within the officer report an objection
is raised to the principle of the
proposed development by reason of its
location outside of the defined
settlement boundary which would result
in harm to the character of the area
the evidence applied as part of the
application is not considered adequate
to sufficiently justify that there is an
essential or functional need for the
building in this location
which due to its size and separation
from the existing garden center together
with its operating hours is not
considered ancillary to the wider garden
center use operating at the site
restaurants are considered a main town
centre use under the mppf and without an
ancillary link to the garden center the
cafe is considered to be an independent
facility which would not be directly
linked to the existing youth contrary to
policy e4
there is also an extent permission that
allows a cafe to be provided at the site
and if the proposal was granted planning
permission there would be the potential
to provide two cafes at the site
furthermore insufficient parking
provision would be available at the site
and as such the application is
recommended for refusal
thank you chairman thank you
uh we have no speakers on this one so i
spotted you first
councillor durham council of white
councillor morgan
uh thank you thank you chairman i did
actually call this in um and uh it is in
my ward
and you know members and officers know
that
you know in general
i will always support policy um and
policy is always the first thing that we
should be guided by
but not where the policy doesn't make
any sense at all and he's actually
indefensible
because to have a policy saying that a
cafe or a restaurant can only be in a
town centre is barking mad i'm sorry
and
you know i know chairman i know exactly
i would draw your country pubs
restaurants in rural locations garden
centers there are two garden centers
within a mile and a half of this
particular one both have that's white
elms and west view both have
coffee shops and restaurants
there are i'm afraid an essential part
of garden centers now and people going
to a garden center
expect it this one is actually only
going to be open during lunch time so of
course it's going to be ancillary to be
to the uh well it's going to be
ancillary to the um
to the garden center
so
you know i'm afraid if we if we have to
stand up and say well we we're going to
refuse it and we go to appeal to say you
know we shouldn't have catering
facilities
you know anywhere except on a high
street we'd be laughed out of an appeal
so chairman um i this particular garden
center i've used it for many many many
years
it had previously gone into terminal
decline
and due to lack of investment
that since a new owner has acquired it
he has spent
a considerable amount of money
smartening it up because the
the competition in that sector is
incredibly tough and in order to survive
you need all of the facilities and and
i'm afraid that includes um
a catering facility on site so chairman
as i said i will always go to a policy
first but not when it doesn't make any
sense and i will therefore
propose that we don't follow the
officer's recommendations as a refusal
but i'm happy to
um
to propose that we uh approve this
application
mr lee wants to come back on the times
because that's not correct but in any
case we don't have a proposal to second
because i need your reasons
and they have to come
with the proposal as a job block
otherwise people might imagine that the
person making the proposal doesn't
actually know what they're doing
no i'm sorry
i need you from counseling yes of course
you could speak but i i'm going to
instantly refer tell us about the hours
thank you chairman um number of points
i'd like to bring is that it isn't the
council's policy that uh towns
restaurants town centre locations that's
the government's policy as the officer
pool explains it's contained within the
mppf that i'm sure the members have read
the report fully so they are aware of
that so i don't think say will be
laughed out of appeal as a starting
point when that's actually the
government's advice that we should be
locating restaurants in town centres
i don't know the definitive assumption
for that i would assume it's doing
sustainable transport and not to have
people that live in sustainable areas
traveling to unsustainable areas to have
to eat irrespective of that the policy
has three
teeth one of them is that the uh there's
a functional need and justifiable
um i don't disagree that it's a
relatively common practice to have a
cafe with something such as a garden
sentiment
and i think you know the council's
position on that is referenced by the
valley it wasn't that long ago we
granted
permission for a development that is
extent that includes a relatively small
cafe the applicant if they so wish can
implement that tomorrow they could be
doing it right now and we have no
control over that as an authority what
they are doing is submitting an
application for a separate building
which is a lot larger
restaurant and we consider for many
reasons partly the separation part of
the separate access part partly the
letter from the person that's actually
runs the uh
um
garden center that's highlighting that
the hours are much later that's within
the application then are proposed for
the garden set at the moment for those
multiple reasons that this isn't an
ancillary
uh development that ties in with the
existing garden center so i think that's
the first point is that the uni it's not
looking at the principle of a cafe with
this garden center what we're looking at
is this
structure is this development a
restaurant in its own right that sits
separate to the garden center members
can make their own decision but i just
obviously always want to make sure that
members are looking at the right
considerations when determining the
application as i said the count there is
a
extent permission so they can put
a cafe in there tomorrow and it wasn't
that long ago that the council granted
that as an ancillary relationship with
the garden center but this proposal is
slightly different and i said there's
three teeth which are highlighted in
paragraph five point one point nine of
the offices report that or hurdles that
you need to get over for e4
and they are that there's adjustable
and functional need for the building
activity officers say for the scale
partly but secondary to the fact that
there is an extent permission provides
one it doesn't meet that part the
function of the proposed building
activities directly linked to ancillary
to the existing use
similar reasons distance opening hours
separate access extent permission
officers to consider this proposal for
this development not the principle of a
cafe this specific development doesn't
meet that test and then the third one is
that the building activity could not
reasonably be located in existing towns
villages or allocate employment areas as
i said mppf says that restaurants which
officers consider this is not ancillary
cafe separate development should be in
town centres and you've got to remember
that just like with all development it's
not about the person it's not about the
applicant just because this is the only
land that they're able to get
access for for a development on isn't a
material consideration for us as
decision makers so
members need to consider whether or not
this proposal is
ancillary or whether it is a separate
independent restaurant and if so is it a
pr is there a reason why this restaurant
should be here rather than a town centre
where members or so where the government
consider that and obviously if members
go against the officers the reason for
approval will need to talk to those
three
points about you know and i'll look
forward to that thank you
i'll just come back i'll come back very
quickly
yes
mr lee uh yeah look i i totally accept
that but i i think
on the flip side of this we have to be
realistic we we
we need to be supporting local
businesses we need to be supporting
local employment opportunities
and you know that this will this will
tick the box white the the cafe on the
coffee shop restaurant it is more at
west view which is about a mile and a
half down the road in big maker is in
the jumpsuit district that again is a
completely separate building to the rest
of the garden center
so you know i
i just think that we are penalizing um a
local business
um needlessly and you know for that
reason um i'm i'm going to wait for
councillor white spells of wisdom but
then i will uh
i will um come back with my proposal or
somebody else can put a proposal all i
need i don't mind who it is but if
there's going to be a proposal for an
overturn it has to come in one bunch
right i do in fact i'll read out my
little notes i've got council white
council morgan
councillor fleming and then councillor
sittle
oh
i'm sorry i didn't notice
where was council morning quite early
but yeah i haven't actually got the
council of keys to talk robert
i don't think you could see councilman
oh i see copper council that would
explain it right okay councilman i'm
going to
pop you in ladies first i'm going to pop
you in after council mrs fleming right
council councillor white off you go
thank you man
right well
firstly i've already said my husband
said i'm addicted to buying trees and
then
i i personally regularly visit white
house which has a cafeteria not my
favorite one meadowcroft
by bob tim's the leader on many
occasions they've got a really good
canteen their cafe there perry with a
tip tree another one that's really nice
afternoon teas on the a127 summer hill
coming back from the gym and playing
tennis we often call in there for brunch
and of course high paul has two or three
different restaurants on the high school
so you know this is a really common
thing it's not
unusual it's not alone in fact animal's
writing school has got deb's diner and
deb's diner which we call the hair
enforce was actually the white house
development opposite was a truth because
it was classed as a um very good local
facility so that's the first one and now
i write down the policy um
and on 4.1
the first part says the district's
economy comprises employment in high
quality manufacturing construction
business and lifestyle general industry
as well as non-traditional employment
incentives such as educational health
retail and tourism all these sectors has
a positive contribution for local
regional and national economy the
vitality diversity and responsiveness of
the economy is fundamental to the future
prosperity for the district and its
position in the within the wider economy
so i think it's implied that five
equality 4.1 then we go on to policy 4.5
the council will need to build upon the
district's economic strength and i'm
diversified because i need to provide a
wide range of job opportunities for the
future i also think it complies with
policy 4.5
and now if you go at the end of policy
e1 which is on page 64.
if i can find it the council will
support
the development of better quality and
flexible local employment space media
employment target all new employment
space should seek to meet the needs of
local businesses and attract inward
investment this insight that's being
invested
and then we go on to
policy policy 4.7
um through the north district council
eps the council is seeking to maintain a
vibrant and competitive economy which
balances the needs of global businesses
while sustaining a high quality of life
increasing incomes and promoting the
mobile district is a great place to live
play work and do business
um
and then it could conclude by saying
which includes increasing high quality
business premises supporting
diversification and enterprise
improving skills they offer training
there and training provision and
improving transport and broadband-based
connectivity which aren't so liable so
for me i think we should approve this
application
because i believe that um
compliance policies of e1 which are 5.1
4.5
and 4.7 so i believe that this
application complies with policy e1
education so i think this application
should be improved because the benefits
outweigh them
see you chairman
officers don't disagree with a lot of
what you know councillor white said as
she's read out sections of the policy or
the adopted plan all i'd highlight is
that policy e4 which wasn't what was
spoken about relates to raw
diversification that would be the policy
that this application should be assessed
against rather than the broader
employment policy the four draws down on
that to more specific matters of rural
diversification
say is that there is nothing spoken
about policy for in that and what i
would concern is that if members support
that reason for approval
you're basically saying any employment
use in the district is acceptable
irrespective of any other policy because
it's not talking about anything
i understand each policy on its merits
i'm personally always advised that but
you need to be able to talk specifically
about the benefits of this specific
film
rather than um just very generic broad
statement i'm not gonna be picky but to
be on the more succinct the better but
um
part one there's a justifiable possible
need for the building or activity to
expand the local business
uh the function of the both person is
directly linked to the existing
movements run by the same owners
number three the building through
activity could not be located in
existing town solutions or allocated
employment areas because it is a rural
business in rural buildings in a rural
area and it excludes tourism
um
the point of part d the entertainment
will not limit the impact on wildlife
and natural environment in fact it
actually improves natural environment
because it's providing um
plants to be um
so i think it doesn't require poverty
for those reasons
to come here but you can
before we actually get poor miss bird to
take that down how much of that did you
get by the way miss bird
god
is that the officer paul has reason in
behind why we have said its country to
policy the reason proposal should talk
to the policy obviously talk to the
issues we've had we've discussed things
in the office report about the separate
access different opening hours the
extent permission etc
and then members just saying this is a
real development therefore it's
justifiable linked etc would mean in
principle
if we were to take this as a base point
any application that came in on the
world development said i own this piece
of land i want to build this as an
employment use and i have nothing else
in theory would be acceptable you need
to be able my advice is members you need
to speak to what the officer report
talks about the concerns because if
you're not
you are literally throwing the policy
out and that is what my concerns are
members and all i can advise you to do
is to think about what the office report
says and look at those concerns and
understand that remembering at the end
of the day there was an extent
permission on this site for a cafe so
that we could end up with two and
secondly
the uh the person that is running the uh
garden center has written in
highlighting that this development will
have different hours because it's not
being run by the same person that's fine
in the cafe it may be on land that's
owned it's being run but so some of the
points have been raised by members are
actually in total conflict with what the
evidence we have before us as part of
the application as always i'd advise
members of decision makers as we do as
officers to base it on evidence rather
than things that we've heard that we do
not have as formal submissions as part
of the application as always it's within
members gift to determine applications
they would but please be very conscious
of what the office report says and that
every other thing that goes against
every time member go against it it is a
material consideration in future
applications thank you chairman i'm
gonna go around the people who haven't
spoken yet so we've got councillor
morgan
followed by council of fleming followed
by councillor morley councillor siddall
and
well actually we run out of first timers
then we're back to councillor darwin i
dare say
i really just wanted to
support um councillor white's um
proposal there uh and we just point out
in terms of policy e4 there is a
justifiable and functional need for the
building i go further than that i think
it was actually a social need probably
dragged to a number of these things
myself but i just there there needs to
be a facility for non-gardening people
to be able to find some form of respite
refreshment um but on a more serious
note i i there is no
facility of this nature that i've
certainly beaten by god i've been to a
number of them where there is not this
sort of facility here and i don't think
there's
this
just a cafe or a t-stop is not doesn't
cut it anymore these places need to
attract a quality clientele who demand
the right uh facilities and the right
level of food and refreshment thank you
benjamin
thank you
yes
all i'll just say is that you know
officers aren't saying that ancillary
service isn't appropriate all we're
highlighting is that there is a number
of reasons that this
proposal does not come across on ceiling
at no stages any members discussed the
concerns that officers have in the
report we just keep talking about the
principle of it and secondly
there is an extent permission for a cafe
on site already so this permission would
allow to
that you know and that's all i want to
get to crosstalk members is that
they're
we aren't raising objection in principle
to the idea of a cafe on this site
that's ancillary it's just
and members seem to be
seem to have taken the recommendation
refusal as that that is not what the
recommendation refusal relates to i
would just like to direct members to the
office of the pool what it says and if
members wish to go against it i said
it's always within their gift they think
about those points because otherwise
it's really been very diff very
disrespectful for one of the better
phrase the policy and it's going to make
it very hard if decisions like this have
become regular to actually use this
policy in the future and this is a very
important policy for the district as it
deals with overall diversification and
businesses you know you've got to
understand how important if we
don't talk to this application
specifically we are
under our undermining the policy thank
you chair
councillor fleming
thank you chair i wanted to ask mr
liabel and the officers about the extent
permission you referenced something
about an access um
being put in i is that actually the one
directly onto the 414 to the molden road
there is a drop kerb sort of near the
bus stop so i just wanted to know about
that
um first thank you and then come back
yes through you chairman um there
is an existing access onto the malden
road but that is not in use and no
changes have been made to that as part
of the previous permission the previous
permission allowed an extension to the
existing access
from bryant's lane on into the garden
center so because they have implemented
that part of the previous permission
that permission is now extant so it has
not expired and therefore they can
implement the cafe function as part of
the extensions to the existing building
which they have not yet done they could
still do that
so um and
the
did you want to know about the highways
comments about the access onto the
malden road yes please there have been
comments as part of the application
about the potential to provide an access
from malden road
onto the site as part of that existing
access
but it highways are not supportive of
that so
that it does not include part of this
application and there's not been a
material consideration in this instance
thank you jen
thank you chair our members should know
that this particular stretch of road
features heavily in my inbox the weight
of traffic the lack of crossings there
for wood and watermelon is a village cut
in two
most of the residents actually live
on the opposite side
um
so i mean that's my concerns focus
around that in that
uh you know if you're going to walk from
the village how do you how do you get
there you have to cross a 50 mile an
hour road with no pedestrian islands
so that's my concern
i mean don't get me wrong i i hate
cooking and food preparation so the more
restaurants
or cafes in the district the better but
i think that the officers in their
reason for refusal
their third reason about the car parking
because i too know that site very well
uh i i think that they got that dead
right
thank you
it's there okay thank you very much so
i've got councillor morley next
um
oh sorry sorry councilman
i was just going to
raise um it's 75 car parking spaces
short of what is required as part of the
extant permission as well as the
additional cafe building and being an
unsustainable location and rural site we
would expect cars to be driving to the
site um
and that is a substantial shortfall
so
yeah thank you
councilman
yep thank you
um as regards the pollution to locating
in towns more restaurants is there extra
parking being provided for all the
houses that have been built
and also
i think
so many pubs are in decline in closing
now
i'm sure
it wouldn't hurt just to help a little
bit of local employment
but it's the pollution mainly shoving
everything in the town
must go against
your instincts i would have thought
ultimately
um
no it's the quick answer what i would
assume is because
the actual level of pollution if you've
got lots of people traveling to lots of
places is actually more than
sustained but yeah but in the big pitch
there'd be more please but it's not in
our policy it's not government guidance
to do that and we should be respecting
our policies and government guidance
thank you
okay councillor siddal i'm sorry you've
waited very patiently thank you
um so my first question is
when does a building become ancillary
and when does it when is it yeah so when
is it not ancillary so that's yeah so
you say there's no ancillary link
so
for there to be an ancillary link
what would need to happen
thank you chairman um
sorry
can you just location plan or block that
um as always with things such as this
it's and i think pretty sure counselor
siblings knows i'm going to say this is
a palin planning judgment and it's
balanced decision um
you want to show the
existing
where it is sorry the existing no sorry
about the one you were showing so where
the
proposed plan yeah the existing
to show that as in it says the approved
existing garden center there
and then show where the restaurant is as
you can see members quite a distance
away
so there's firstly there is just a sheer
physical separation of the appearance of
two separate developments rather than
being a close
ancillary knit secondly it has its own
access in this instance
thirdly
there is
the proposed opening hours are very
different to what the garden center
would be it's very unlikely that people
will be
coming to the site after the garden
center is shut to be using the building
ancillary to the garden center because
it's closed and fourthly and as we've
said before
there is potential for already to have
an ancillary
uh cafe within the building so this
would be a second
development which is much quite a large
development on its own
there's a fifth point so that those five
things together have collectively made
officers come to the uh judgment in
plaque based in planning terms that this
isn't ancillary for those five various
points do we know
how many covers
are proposed for the existing cafe and
how many covers are proposed for this
restaurant
um
for you chairman um yes
anything that's not cruella or you okay
absolutely fine
thank you um yes so that's been
considered within the officer report um
under paragraph
5.1.14. so as part of the application
the applicant suggested that
the previous cafe which is integral to
the extended um garden center would have
96 seating spaces and the proposed cafe
building would have 88
and have suggested that because it would
have less covers that it would therefore
be acceptable um but the existing cafe
would have an area of 170 square meters
and the proposed building would have an
area of 506 square meters
295 of which would be
the the dining area including the bar
the bar service area the lounge and the
seating area so
although
they have suggested that the seating
covers would be less the we have no way
to enforce that and
the area is larger basically so the area
is larger so immediately yeah and we
can't we can't uh there's no material
there's no uh policy that we can say in
terms of the number of covers that they
would implement so immediately that
causes issues with the car parking yeah
we're gonna you know it's it's twice the
size of the the cafe they got permission
for so that's gonna double
yeah and then you've got all the people
coming to the to the uh nursery so i
understand that there's a need for this
but they've got that need satisfied in
the existing building
and this is not
expanding the existing business this is
a different business it's not the same
business and that's the crucial thing i
think if it was something in terms of
saying okay yeah we're going to make our
building a bigger
cafe well they're doing that so in in
terms of the need for this new building
i really cannot see it and we have to
support the offers as recommendation on
this because otherwise we are driving a
coaching horses through our employment
policy and that's a very very as i've
heard at this community before a very
risky thing to do
um yeah so not only in terms of it
expanding the business the whole issue
around the car park and in terms of that
that building that that extra building
is going to make a huge difference and
impact on that area so i can see that it
does have an impact on the design and
the countryside you are not going to see
a nice garden center as you drive around
that corner as you come into the
district you're going to see some
whacking great buildings
thank you i know you want to come back
count to down but how nice what what
what buildings are where the extent
permission for the cafe are present i'm
just wondering if they made a unilateral
undertaking to give up the extent
permission
would that in some miraculous way create
enough parking
for the bus for the new business the new
building that we're looking at
do you chairman um the extent permission
also does include an increase in retail
area so obviously if that they were to
expunge that permission
obviously the overall car parking
requirement would
relatively quite you know would reduce
obviously there would be space that
could be accommodated but at the moment
there is no 6 106 or anything with any
of the within the submission saying they
are willing to give up that permission
which they can do legally they haven't
included that and that situation we are
where legally they could have too if
they were to do that would it be
acceptable i'll be honest i i don't know
because that hasn't been assessed and
it's members now i don't really like to
make things up thank you
fair enough councillor durham i've got
you to come back and councillor white
kevin thank you look um
officers aren't going to agree aren't
going to agree with with some of our
thinking and we're not you know
going to agree with their thinking
necessarily um
councillor morgan hit the nail on the
head just doing tnt cakes and the
afternoon team buns isn't enough anymore
perry woods has been cited perry woods
has an annual tournament in the public
records has an annual turnover of about
7 million
and nearly 2 million of that is the
restaurant
you know it's a very significant um
part of that business when we're getting
over policies
i would say
we're not we're not we're not giving a
cart blanche for every single employment
opportunity
we are concentrating and in line with
our policies to support tourism and
hospitality businesses
and the rural economy and you know that
i think in a nutshell is
i still believe sufficient grounds for
um for agreeing this application
problem is telling a proper proposal but
you know i've got to sound inclined very
much to agree with councillor siddill's
assessment because i'd thoroughly
support an ancillary cafe
but they've got that and perry woods as
you point out which in fact has two but
they only open for breakfast and lunch
they're not even accessible when the
garden center is itself is closed and
you know if you get there if you get
there after lunch you know it's team
cake
and that's
what i expect from a garden center not a
restaurant you know we're up we've got
the one inch in chibra road in um
opposite mill beach
that's been refused under the same
policies
i don't much like it nor does the
applicant but i can see why
yeah well can can we have a succinct
proposal with the policies even if it's
you know the
diversification is more important though
4.5
well that's that's e4 and
we've got that same thing by council
keys
have you got that miss bird
right we've got sorry sorry that that's
a yes miss bird right that's councillor
durham's points no additions that's
councillor durham's points otherwise
it's
otherwise it's a mangled proposal right
so i will put that to the vote those
four councillor durham's proposal
one two three
five those against
that application is approved
oh yes that we've got to delegate yeah
conditions well i would obviously
say i would obviously if members are
saying that this is ancillary that we
would suggest a condition that says the
opening hours are tied into the uh yeah
i'm just very conscious that obviously
if we're trying to say this is ancillary
development it needs to be remain and
philosophy
we have to delegate the conditions we've
done that item seven is any other items
of business chairman decides are urgent
you'll be pleased to hear there are none
thank you very much members for staying
the whole duration of the meeting i now
draw the meeting to a close at 8.56
thank you